hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news live from cop26 here in
glasgow today
more money pledged for green finance as
chancellor rishi sunak claims a 130
trillion dollar promise from private
firms is historic
but countries on the front line of the
climate crisis
say rich nations have not delivered the
cash promised over a decade ago
we see the impact in madagascar as whole
towns are facing ecological destruction
and deforestation is the only way for
some to survive
protests in glasgow as demonstrators say
companies are claiming to do more to
protect the environment than they really
are
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show we are
live for you from the heart of the cop26
summit here in glasgow and there's been
lots of talk about money here today the
promise of an eye-watering 130 trillion
dollars of private capital to help fund
the green transition was described by
the former bank of england governor mark
carney as a watershed moment but a
long-standing promise by developed
countries to fund 100 billion dollars a
year for those on the front line of the
climate crisis will be met three years
late well we'll hear more about both of
those shortly but first
more than a million people are on the
brink of famine in madagascar it's a
country experiencing its worst drought
in 40 years as crops and livestock have
been devastated many are now turning to
deforestation just to survive
but that in turn is making the climate
emergency worse
our special correspondent alex crawford
reports now from focap in the grand sood
region of madagascar
the shifting sand info cap in the
southern tip of madagascar blankets
everything
is threatening livelihoods and burying
homes and buildings this was the police
station
and this the local government office now
so covered were able to stand on its
roof
the phenomenon known here as teomina or
red storm has been dramatically changing
this indian ocean coastline ravaging
crops and stifling development
the people here have been hit by a long
drought but also fierce winds which
often halt the fishing which is one of
the main sources of income
henry claude the head of the village
hasn't been out on the water for more
than a week now
some of the brave or the desperate opt
for other methods but it can be
dangerous and often fruitless
henry claude shows us the rows of sizal
trees the village has planted to try to
restore this degraded land and rescue
the ecosystem
it's a long-term strategy with the
greenest of weapons
how worried are you
that even more of the village is going
to be buried in sand
many of them are just plain scared not
just of the future but the here and now
we're afraid of living here he says and
many people are leaving
they're afraid of the invasion by the
dunes and we just can't get investment
here
the violent winds blow off roofs and
make a living that's already hard even
harder
and there are signs many of the
villagers have already abandoned their
homes and been forced to move on
so they're turning to other ways to
survive
and by the look of this market
madagascar's forests are being plundered
and sold at an alarming rate
[Applause]
but all this has added to large-scale
deforestation with madagascar losing 40
of its forest since the 1950s
when
we don't have anything to eat we don't
have anything to drink we cut the wood
because of the care he says
cassie will be lucky if she sells any of
her sweet potatoes she'll maybe make 2
thousand arie about half a dollar but
she has seven other children as well as
her baby
it's hard she says i'll spend half on
water and half on rice for the baby the
others
and right now madagascar is burning away
its future to get through the present
racking up one of the highest rates of
deforestation in any tropical country
that's put its ecosystem at risk
destroying its habitat and putting the
vast range of unique wildlife it's home
to in great danger
we spotted an extremely rare radiated
tortoise out in the open and lifted it
away from the road it's critically
endangered and only found here in the
south of madagascar but it's being
killed for its meet or captured by
poachers at such a rate that
conservationists warn it could disappear
from the wild forever within 20 years
the people of this island are among the
poorest in the world yet the country has
an abundance of natural riches with more
than a hundred different species of lima
living in the wild for instance and the
island so large it's more than double
the size of britain
that there are different but equally
serious problems across the nation as we
found when we traveled here into the
forest on the eastern coast
sinji's been traveling through this
forest for two decades he's never seen
it so bad
it's not good the chain the trend coming
hot
high hot
and dry
right and
the rain coming
if they come
rain too much
no stop
and flat everywhere
the malagasy government has so many
tough challenges and weaning its
population off its dependence on coal
and wood is just one of them and right
now for so many here raiding the
nation's natural resources is seen as
the only way to survive
alex crawford sky news in the grand sue
region of madagascar
well let's return now to the
developments that have been taking place
here at the cop26 summit today day three
where finance has been the focus and
despite announcements on both private
and public funds there is anger from
climate vulnerable nations that there's
still not enough money being put forward
to help address the issues that they're
facing right now our science and
technology editor tom clark reports
in a way this summit is all about money
moving cash away from fossil fuels and
seeing more flow to poor countries most
at risk from climate change today's slew
of announcements on new streams of green
finance
my simple goal is that the message we
want coming out loud and clear from
glasgow is that whatever climate
ambitions we set over the next couple of
weeks the finance is there to deliver
them it finally looks like that much
needed climate funding has finally
started to arrive but everyone in this
room knows it's nothing like enough cash
flowing fast enough to meet the scout of
the challenge
do countries like madagascar for example
which is living in the climate emergency
feel confident that investment is about
to start flowing their way larry
absolutely
for the bahamas hit in 2019 by dorian
the most powerful atlantic hurricane
ever recorded it's about fairness shown
to those who suffer by those who pollute
my yesterday
is your tomorrow
i had my dorian
what will yours be
and route the finances being made
available and loosen up
i will not be able to adapt
will not be able to mitigate
and that who will be next
you
who hoard
stockpile
keep the resources to yourselves you
will not be safe unless we are also
but the idea at this summit launched
today by the energetic money men is that
trillions in cash will follow the
billions in public money now financial
institutions have agreed to go to net
zero two well it look the city has
mobilized the finance it's led on this
there's more than enough capital
committed today than the world needs for
the next 30 years but can we believe the
banks when they say they'll walk away
from fossil fuel profits what we need to
do is transition we're rewiring the
whole economy into a more sustainable
economy from our perspective we've
committed to end harmful financing so
for example oil and gas is less than 0.8
of the lending on our balance sheet we
have been reducing that and with those
customers that we do have we're only
going to work with them if they have a
credible transition plan aligned with
paris no single summit could switch the
world's economy away from fossil fuels
we won't fix the climate crisis until
that happens but cop 26 looks like it
has at least set that process in motion
well tom is here in the studio with me
now 130 trillion sounds like a lot of
money but questions about just how ready
and available that money is for net zero
investments absolutely
if as mark hardy said to me earlier if
they have that money that's 30 years
worth of decarbonisation into the future
it would pretty much get this project
massively off onto the right track
but you've got to remember it's a bit
like one of those financial adverts this
is how much your investment could be
worth if everything falls into line and
yet yeah it hasn't yet done that
although the requirements put out by
rishi sunac today for reporting of your
your carbon exposure your net zero
targets that is mandatory the rest of
this is all guidance this is what we
want to see financial institutions to do
how much they'll actually fall in line
with that we don't yet know and that's
why developing countries are still
pretty skeptical about all of this you
know are we actually going to see that
money and the reason they are is they
want to see that 100 billion dollars
they were promised back in paris
actually hit the deadline which is you
know next year uh which was actually
this year but it looks like it's going
to be next year if they can if they can
get that that will help boost confidence
what rishi sunak and mark honey would
tell you once you have that public money
available these other trillions will
start to follow but again until that
money's there on the table i think they
need to restore that trust and that's
what this summit really is always going
to be about is rebuilding that trust
yeah signaling value okay tom thank you
well we have heard a lot of
big numbers today here at the cop 26
summit in both billions and trillions as
we were hearing from public and private
sources but what do these figures
actually all mean and who is spending
what well sky's economics editor ed
conway has all the details
this is supposedly finance day at cop
but it might better be called big
numbers day i'm going to show you why
we've had lots of big numbers today i
mean one of them was 130 trillion
dollars the other was a hundred billion
dollars we're all getting a bit number
blind here so let's just kind of go into
what these actually mean starting with
130 trillion now the starting point for
this is imagine all of the assets in the
world everything investments uh you've
got mortgages the whole thing it's about
300 trillion dollars give or take it's a
big number and what this is talking
about is that firms that control about
130 trillion have committed to the
glasgow finance agreement on net zero
they're saying that they're going to
control those investments so they keep
to net zero it doesn't mean that all of
that slice is actually going towards
spending money on solar panels or
renewables but it does mean that those
companies are really behind net zero it
doesn't mean i should say that the rest
of them so that remaining two-thirds
aren't in favor of net zero it just
means they haven't signed up to it yet
so this is kind of a formalization of
where the financial system is more of
them committing to these kinds of
agreements that's 130 trillion slightly
meaningless uh if you ask me but 100
billion is a bit more tangible this is
about the money that rich countries are
promising to give to poorer countries to
help them mitigate climate change and
convert to renewables and so on and the
hope was to get that up to 100 billion
by 2020 and here's where things actually
stand so in recent years you can see
we've got up to kind of nearly 80
billion by 2019 but we're not going to
hit that or we didn't hit it in 2020 we
know that we're not going to hit it this
year which was the hope it looks more
like 2023. you can see that's when the
bar goes above that line
but here's the thing again this is quite
complicated and what we do what we
should do is just focus on one of these
bars so let's look at 2018 and break it
down it's about 78 billion in total but
of that okay we'll take that 78 billion
of that a good chunk is the private
sector rather than the public sector so
companies giving money to poorer
countries some as export credits as well
and if we drill into that public sector
bit specifically of that 61.6 billion
the vast majority 47 billion or so is
loans so it's not giving money it's
actually lending money and expecting it
to be repaid fair enough but it's
slightly different from what people
describe this typically as and of that
total you might be wondering how much is
the uk well it's that red slice 1.6
billion dollars or so it's actually a
little bit less than you might have
expected which is strange given the uk
is encouraging other countries to pay
more
well let's take a look at some of the
other day's news now from cop 26 and of
course around the world the prime
minister has returned to westminster and
has been reflecting on whether cop 26
will be successful in keeping the
warming target of 1.5 degrees alive or
boris johnson told mps that words still
need to be turned into action to avoid
climate disaster
in the end mr speaker it is a question
of will
we have the technology to do what is
necessary
all that remains in question is our
resolve
the negotiations in glasgow have almost
two weeks to run
but we can take heart from what has been
achieved so far
well mclaren has unveiled its new
extreme e-car at cop26 there it is
prince charles was one of the first to
see the british-based team's offering
for the off-road electric race series
which aims to raise awareness about
climate change by racing in environments
that are already suffering from the
effects of global warming
he's been busy prince charles has also
been dipping his toe in the sustainable
fashion world teaming up with stella
mccartney and leonardo dicaprio who also
made another cop 26 appearance the
designer is showcasing sustainable
fashion options and technologies at a
cop26 event calling for better
environmental regulation in the industry
we're probably the most unfashionable
industry and the most behind industry
really which is is shocking our industry
has taken too long i think
you know primarily because we have no
policies in place we're not regulated in
any way and i'm really pleasing with the
politicians here to give us some
guidelines
and australia has employed goats in an
effort to reduce devastating wildfires a
40 strong herd are chewing their way
through undergrowth that can fuel
wildfires across high-risk areas in new
south wales ministers say the use of
grazing goats are in response to a
recommendation of the independent
inquiry into the 2019-2020 bushfires
now there have been big protests in
glasgow today with thousands of people
taking part in an anti-green washing
protest our correspondent james matthews
was there and he sent us this report
[Applause]
there's been a lot of talk about the
police operation at comp 26.
here for the first time it was put to
the text
what started out as a protest against
so-called green washing by industry and
government and against the cambo oil
field
evolved into these scenes in the center
of glasgow
a march that hadn't been arranged in
advance with the police splintered into
different city streets
groups of demonstrators were pursued by
police officers at pays
this wasn't a riot but there was some
confrontation in a situation that was
flew
in a police operation involving officers
from around the uk
this was city of london police dealing
with demonstrators who locked themselves
onto the building of the firm sse
over the course of the day a small
number of arrests were made and some
police officers had paint sprayed in
their faces
in the thick of it all were protesters
with the point to make
so in this demonstration
is about how so many companies are
spending more money
to make themselves look green than they
are spending on actually making the
change for this network to protect our
planet at the end of the day this is an
existential threat to humanity and we
need to be doing all that we can we need
to be led by the science this is what
we've seen over the past couple of hours
police lines
trying to contain demonstrators street
by street in an effort to secure the
city centre but it's been a very fluid
situation
if protesters were prevented from making
their way through the city centre
nessie the loch ness monster was stopped
from swimming up the river climb
it had been a gesture by anti-poverty
campaigners until police ruled it out
ladies and gentlemen
politics in all its form has come to
glasgow if they didn't know it before
they do know james matthews sky news
glasgow
well we're discussing all of those
climate issues of the day now with
senior teaching fellow at the school of
oriental and african studies and founder
of sofinder felicia jackson and the
founding director of the oxford
sustainable finance program at the
university of oxford smith school of
enterprise and the environment dr ben
caldecott good evening to both of you
it's been a busy day hasn't it and ben i
want to come to you first 130 trillion
dollars it sounds like a hell of a lot
of money doesn't it but it's not a pot
of money that's just sitting there it's
not an investment fund is it no it's not
it's not a pot of money in a bank
account or an investment fund but it is
all the assets that have committed to
net zero by 2050 and those assets have
also committed to interim targets to
make sure that they make progress
there's still a lot to do though and i
think one of the things that we need to
spend much more time on is focusing on
the integrity of those commitments how
we're going to make sure that people's
promises
are
implemented and that's why we need to
invest in tracking infrastructure and
make sure that governance arrangements
are in place and that was why the
announcement this morning from russia
sunak is really very significant because
he was talking about the need for net
zero transition plans across the economy
that creates a new first of a kind
regulatory framework for companies and
financial firms to think about these
issues very big announcement yeah
mandatory reporting from 2023 that's a
big step isn't it felicia it is a big
step that but it's a fundamental one i
mean one of the key issues with any
announcement about commitments is where
is the accountability
and i think anyone who makes a
commitment today knows that they're
going to be tracked they know that
they're going to be asked what they're
going to do and by when but in the end
we need to get an alignment of all
companies and all financial institutions
towards the same goal otherwise we're
not going to encourage the financial
flows that we need
130 trillion as we're saying it's not a
pot of money sitting there but it's
still a lot of money isn't it and you've
got to think that if you can't solve the
climate crisis with that amount of money
then should we just give up well i think
one of the things that's interesting
that was said this morning is that that
amount of assets under management means
that we could
relatively easily
do the hundred trillion that we actually
need to affect the low carbon transition
but again the question is what are the
frameworks that are encouraging that
money to be invested in the right way
one of the big challenges is a lot of
those financial institutions are still
heavily invested in fossil fuels and as
long as that's the case
we're not really going to get to the
transition as quickly as we need
questions about who's going to be
monitoring this uh 2050
is the um is the target date isn't it
for those assets under management
but you can't just have a sudden uh
killing of an industry can you you have
to sort of unwind it gradually what do
you think about that
so
the this 130 trillion needs to be guided
by
transition plans with regular reporting
of progress and that needs to be put on
a regulatory footing and the uk is the
first to to do that
and in addition to that of course we
need to make sure that the real economy
the changes that are happening around
the world
people that are affected companies are
affected get the capital they need get
the support they need and one thing we
need to do is to convert polluting
companies into clean ones and they're
going to need capital to do that so we
need financial markets to provide them
with the resources they need to
transition as well the other pots of
money that of course we've been talking
about is that hundred billion dollars a
year that was pledged in 2009 in
copenhagen looks like i mean we're
certainly going to fall short talk of it
being met in 2023 have you seen
promising signs around that felicia very
much so i mean there have been so
there's been so many different
announcements that it was a huge problem
when it was announced that it wasn't
going to be met because obviously that
undermines the trust in the negotiations
people's ability exactly but with some
of the announcements we've seen in the
last couple of days you know japan
a number of companies sorry countries
have actually said they're going to
contribute larger amounts of climate
finance i think the key thing is the
overall transition because 100 billion
is a drop in the ocean in terms of the
amount of money that's actually needed
what the 100 billion is about is public
commitment from developing countries to
say you know we're asking you to take
action and we're going to stand up to
the plate and provide you with the funds
and the support and the capacity
building that you need to do a just
transition because as ben says you know
you have to be able to transition
people's jobs their livelihoods the way
in which they work so the south african
announcement i thought was brilliant you
know eight and a half billion to
actually transition an economy that's a
huge contributor to emissions yeah final
thought from you ben about that south
african announcement of course an
economy that's hugely dependent on coal
so a really significant announcement and
a first of a kind and something that can
be replicated so developed economies
including the uk the us france germany
the european union have said look we're
going to support south africa's own plan
to decarbonize its energy system and
we're going to provide finance and
funding to support south africa to do
that and technical assistance and i
think and i hope that this will be the
first of many such country-owned
partnerships where the supports provided
to encourage and enable developing
countries and emerging economies to
transition as quickly as possible yeah
that's what been the name of the game
hasn't it all day today it's about how
you get that public and private money to
come together to meet those
environmental pledges okay thank you
very much indeed felicia jackson and dr
ben caldecott's been really great having
you in the studio with us this evening
well don't forget that you can listen to
a new climate cast every day from cop26
that's wherever you normally find your
podcasts you may well already be
watching this on our pop-up channel but
if you're not you can find uninterrupted
coverage from cop 26 here in glasgow
between 9 00 a.m and 7 p.m on channel
525 all week but do stay tuned up next
we have mark austin who has a special
program live from brazil on the climate
crisis thanks for watching good night
[Music]